[موسيقى]
صباح اليوم سأتحدث عن كيف فهمنا
كل شيء بشكل خاطئ لماذا أخطأنا
وكيف يمكننا تصحيحها على
أمل وسأتحدث من
منظور علم الأعصاب لأن
هذا هو ما تخصصت فيه ولكن  أولاً ،
اسمح لي بمشاركة بعض الصور
لأشياء ثمينة جدًا بالنسبة لي إذا كنت تحب
هذا كلبي حقًا وأنت تفهم
سبب أهمية أن أستخدم
ابنة أخي وستفهم سبب
أهميتها أيضًا وهذا د.  كان محمد
حبلة فنانًا بصريًا مصريًا مشهورًا
وستفهم كيف
يرتبط الثلاثة قبل أن أشرح أيًا
من تلك الأشياء ، دعني أتحدث قليلاً عن
الأشياء العلمية العصبية المملة عندما
نتعلم أننا نتعلم من خلال طرق
مختلفة وأولها ربما يكون التقليد
لذلك عندما ترى طفلاً صغيراً
وتخرج لسانك عند الطفل ، فإن
الطفل سيقلد ذلك الذوبان في كثير من الأحيان
في اليوم الذي ينظر فيه إلى
الأطفال حديثي الولادة وأدركوا أنه نعم
إذا بقيت لطيفًا في الخارج ، فسوف
يقلد الطفل ذلك.  يمكنك تجربة ذلك في
المنزل وسيقلد الأطفال
التأثيرات المرئية المتنوعة التي تقوم بها
بتقليد يتضمن عاملًا بشريًا
وتأثيرًا بارزًا الآن هناك طريقة أخرى
للتعلم من خلال تعزيز التحفيز
والمحاكاة وهذا لا
يتضمن بالضرورة عاملًا ولكن
ربما تتضمن التجربة والخطأ ، لذا فإن
المثال الجيد هو قرد صغير
وقرد أم وربما يكون هناك سجل
ويوجد طعام أسفل السجل الآن
لم يكن لدى قرد الأم  أظهر للقرد الصغير
كيفية القيام بذلك ،
يفهم القرد بطريقة ما أن السجل يجعله متعبًا
وأن هناك طعامًا تحته ، لذا في
هذه الحالة يكون لديك هدف بارز
وهو الطعام ولديك التجربة
والخطأ وهذا ماليزي الآن
أخيرًا ، لديك شيء يسمى
المحاكاة وهذا في الأساس
تكرار لسلوك لا يتضمن حقًا
هدفًا أو أي شيء ، لذلك لن أتحدث حقًا
عن تقليد مرة أخرى لتقليد
تأثير عامل بشري بارز ،
تحسينات المحاكاة التجربة والخطأ
تأثير بارز لا يوجد عامل بشري الآن  مرة أخرى
في اليوم في ماكس بلانك ، ما فعلناه
هو أن لدينا أطفالًا صغارًا في ما كان
يسمى بمختبر الأطفال وما يزال
يسمى بالمختبر المتموج وقدمنا
لهؤلاء الأطفال زرين زر أحمر
وزر أزرق ورأينا
أدركنا أنه إذا ضغطت على
الزر الأزرق على سبيل المثال وكان لديك
تأثير بارز ، أي أنه يضيء ويصدر
صوتًا لطيفًا ، فمن المرجح أن
يكرر الطفل ذلك ويفعله  مرات ومرات ،
لذا فإن التردد أعلى في
زمن الانتقال أعلى وكذلك في هذه الأثناء
توصل الرجال في مكان ما في إيطاليا إلى
ملاحظة شيقة للغاية وسأطلب منك بما أنه ليس لدي
أي دعائم
وتخيلني أني أحضر كوبًا من
الماء وأشرب ذلك الآن كما
تتخيل أو تراني أفعل هذا الإجراء
، تطلق الخلايا العصبية في دماغك كما لو
كنت تقوم بهذا الإجراء
نفسه وهو في قشرة دماغك
وهناك فعلوا  تجربة مع
قرد المكاك وكان rizzolatti
وفريقه وأدركوا ما
نسميه الآن الخلايا العصبية المرآتية ، ها هو
القرد الذي يراقب شخصًا ما يلتقط
حبة فول سوداني تُطلق نفس الخلايا العصبية
في دماغ القردة بينما كان القرد
نفسه يلتقط  الفول السوداني الآن بعد
أن تم ذلك عن طريق مخلب ميكانيكي
أو ملاقط في هذه الحالة ، لم تنطلق الخلايا العصبية بشكل
مثير للاهتمام بما يكفي في
مكان آخر في العالم ،
قرر شخص ما القيام بذلك مع طفل بشري
والاهتمام  كان الشيء عندما
تم التقاط اللعبة ، أي أن التأثير البارز تم
التقاطه بواسطة مخلب ميكانيكي
أطلقته الخلايا العصبية وهو أمر مذهل للغاية ، إنه
يظهر أنه ربما هناك شيء آخر
يحدث وربما نقوم بتقليده من
أجل التقليد وربما كما
يطبع Wolfgang  في max planck افترضنا أن
لدينا شيئًا يسمى نظرية التشفير الشائعة ،
أي أن الإجراءات مشفرة في
نتائجها ، لذا فإن التقليد يتم ترميزه من
أجل التقليد ، ثم قررت
مرة أخرى في اليوم أيضًا إجراء
تجربة أخرى ماذا لو كان عملي
مخالفًا للحدس  ما الذي يحدث
إذا كان الإجراء أكثر تعقيدًا بعض الشيء
وفي هذه الحالة أتذكر في ذلك الوقت
كانت شاشة اللمس كبيرة بهذا الحجم وكنت
أتجول مع شاشة اختبار تعمل باللمس ضخمة
في a in a في الجامعة والعودة
في  كان سوقًا يحاول
تجنيد الموضوعات وكانت تلك الموضوعات
أطفالًا صغارًا وقد استخدمت البيض كثيرًا من
الأطفال الصغار في تجربتي وكان
من المروع جدًا في بعض الأحيان
أن يرى الوالدان طالبًا صغيرًا يمشي  k
حول الحقيبة مع سؤال
الوالدين جيدًا ، هل يمكنني استخدام طفلك لإجراء
تجربة ، ستحصل على ثمانية أرطال
وفيديو مجاني ، لذا كان الأمر غريبًا للغاية ،
لكنهم شاركوا وقررت أن أفعل
ما يلي الآن معظمكم لا يعرف
من سيفعل  أنت نقار الخشب هو ذلك
الشيء الموجود هناك ويمضي قدمًا لذا فهو
يخلق تأثيرًا بارزًا ويبدو
رائعًا نوعًا ما وقررت أن أفعل
ما يلي إذا ضغطت
على زر معين على الشاشة
وحدث التأثير البارز  في مكان
آخر على شاشة مختلفة ولكن
على تلك الشاشة سيكرر الطفل
ذلك بنعم أو لا ماذا
لو ضغطت على الزر في الحالة الثانية ولم يحدث شيء ،
فسيقوم الطفل بذلك نعم أو لا
، وأردت أيضًا إلقاء نظرة على
التحفيز التحفيزي ماذا  إذا لم أفعل
شيئًا على الإطلاق وسهم
ينزل على الزر ، فسيتم
تكرار ذلك إذا كان هناك هدف ، فهل
سيخرج نقار الخشب أخيرًا الحالة النهائية
ويشعر بأن شيئًا
لم يحدث الآن سآخذك إلى شيء  في مكان
آخر في العالم لأنه في هذه الأثناء عندما
كنت أفعل ذلك الرجل الذي يدعى محمد
حبلة كان في مكان ما في سويسرا ، كان
لديه طلاب وأدرك أن الناس
يستمتعون بالفعل باستخدام هذه
الطريقة الغريبة المختلفة وكانوا يتتبعون
بعضهم البعض لذا كان يضع شاشة فارغة
شاشة شفافة ونصف
الأشخاص يتتبعون بعضهم البعض ، وقد
استمتع الناس بالفعل بهذا النوع من الغرابة ،
لكنني سأشرح سبب العودة إلى
تجربتي ، أدركت ما يلي
عندما أضغط على الزر ، خرج نقار الخشب الخشبي
، كان التردد مرتفعًا
جدًا الآن ، لذا فهذه هي اليد  بدون أن تأتي عندما
كان لديك لقاء يضغط على الزر ، لا يوجد
تردد ناتج مرتفع للغاية أيضًا
، وهذا هو زمن الانتقال بين قوسين عندما
لا يحدث أي شيء لمحاكاة السهم ،
ثم الترددات منخفضة جدًا
، لذا لم نحصل على أي نتائج هناك عندما
كان هناك  سهم والتأثير البارز
كرر الأطفال ذلك مرارًا وتكرارًا ،
فما الذي يخبرنا به هذا حقًا
عنا إنه مذهل جدًا ، لذا بيل ما  s
Arriba Larabee ephaea goo goo ga
enak شيطان مجهول الهوية مجموعة يانصيب على
أستاذ Doc x 0 dis رجل محظوظ
قاسي من akmahad الجيد د.  آلة التبولة المريضة
إلى
محطة تلام في نيسبيت جيدًا ، منجل أبو منجل
غدًا ، تلتقي سيلينا آنا أو علم الأعصاب
ميكانيكا أليسون ، ستجعل تارا
برج الميزان أنت قرد ليس داخليًا
ليتحول مع [ __ ] مينينا أناندا
ثم هاجيس بنيتي الاجتماعية وبعد
ذلك  هاجر هي محفظة مها مها ،
ثم هاجر هي مها صغيرة ماكينتها جيدًا
ليلي حسنًا ، كان لدي 10 مرحبًا أنا إيلا في
عائلتي في مستشفى في هارلم أغوادا
أليسون كان لديها دراسة الكتاب المقدس أشك
في أن الآلة ستفعل نفس الشيء.
أشك في أن الآلة ستعلق في
البناء الاجتماعي ، أشك في أن الآلة
ستفكر فيما إذا كانت قد قالت
الشيء الصحيح في الوقت الخطأ أو
الشيء الخطأ في الوقت المناسب الذي
تتحرك فيه ولكننا عالقون في
طريقتنا الخاصة لأنك "  لا
تسمح لعقلك بالقيام بالإجراء نيابةً عنك ،
فأنت لا تترك عقلك
يندفع من أجلك ، ثم تصبح
شخصًا يقف في طريقه
مع التاريخ ، يمكنك أن ترى ذلك أيضًا
عند الفكرة.  أو مثال على عائلة نووية
تم اختراعه ربما في الستينيات
أن الأسرة المثالية
والتعايش المثالي هو أب وأم
طفلان يعملان وهذه هي الأسرة ،
هذا بناء اجتماعي
وأنت عالق في ذلك كما قيل من قبل
منذ خمس سنوات مضت ، كانت مصر في
حالة فوضوية ، وبالنظر إلى تلك
الحالة الفوضوية ، لاحظت شيئًا غريبًا حقًا
لاحظت أشخاصًا يرتدون رأس
canizal killa killa hiya الذين
يتصلون مع saguaro gambas بلون alpha هو
لعبتنا المنزلية The Hague a puteri ok  الآن
آلة خارج Lily لن تفعل ذلك
والشيء المذهل عنا نحن البشر هو
أننا نقلد من أجل
التقليد فنحن نعيش
من أجل الوجود
ونتواصل من أجل
التواصل لذلك لا نحتاج حقًا إلى
Woody Woodpecker  هذا الضوء المتوهج
أو ذلك الهدف البارز مجرد التواصل
أو التواجد حول بعضنا البعض أمر جيد
بما فيه الكفاية لذلك في البعض وسأجعله قصيرًا
ولكنه حلو كل تلك التجارب التي أجريناها
منذ عصور ، وبهذا  يعني أنه
ربما في أواخر التسعينيات من
القرن الماضي ، نحن الآن في عام 2017
وأود أن أطلب منك عدم استخدام
عقلك ولكن السماح لعقلك باستخدامك
للسماح لعقلك بالعمل بشكل جيد
لأنه يعمل بشكل مثالي ووجودي
هنا فقط  لتوصيل ذلك الآن
كنقطة أخيرة أتذكرها عندما عدت
من فرنسا التقيت بصديق قديم وكان
ذلك الصديق يحاول تعلم
الفرنسية وسألوني إذا كنت أوصيت بأي
كتاب وقلت حسنًا ، ألبرت كامو هو
كتاب جيد لك  يمكن أن تقرأ عن الأساطير
أو أي شيء ، وأخبرني ذلك الصديق من مصر
أنه أخبرني مضيف لو هاغا موخيتو أخبرني أنهم
يدخنون جاجاجا فيش هاغا هاتف
أواكاكا سمكة يا فتاة جوزيف مو هوك
فكر غريب أن كايين إفريقيا مع
مضيف موسكا كينتون الدولة الإفريقية
muchacho esta sib mocha Costa girl and
ستكون بخير شكرا جزيلا لك
[تصفيق]